recordemos por un momento la fórmula de
la varianza de la población esto nos
decía que teníamos que calcular la
sumatoria de todos los elementos desde
el primero hasta el último de esa
población teniendo en cuenta la
diferencia entre cada uno de los
elementos con la media al cuadrado o el
cuadrado de esa diferencia dividido el
total de los elementos ahora bien esta
fórmula puede ser un poco confusa o no
pero vamos a aprovechar este vídeo para
ver otra alternativa de cómo identificar
a la varianza de una población vamos a
ver otra alternativa que tal vez se haga
más sencilla en mi opinión si se hace
más sencillo y vamos a ver cómo se llega
a ella
si nosotros desarrollamos
este cuadrado del binomio obtendríamos
lo siguiente vamos a desarrollar el
denominador obtendríamos en la sumatoria
de iu igual a 1 a n
de x sube al cuadrado menos 2 veces
x subí por
más el cuadrado de la media al cuadrado
de mí
este sería el desarrollo de ese cuadrado
del binomio ahora bien nosotros sabemos
que todo esto
está dividido por n pero si realizamos
una distributiva de esta sumatoria de
este sigma obtendríamos los siguientes
bajemos acá obtendríamos la sumatoria de
y igual a 1 a n
de x sube al cuadrado menos la sumatoria
igual a 1 en d
mi perdón d
dos veces
por equis zubin más
la sumatoria
a n de muy al cuadrado esto tanto el
numerador el denominador siempre es
dividido en la restante pero prestan
atención a algo en esta cuestión en esta
cuestión la sumatoria a lo único que va
a modificar o lo único de lo que va a
hacerle importancia es a x sub y por lo
tanto estos dos elementos podemos
pasarlos para el otro lado y lo mismo
acá acá no tenemos ningún x sub y por lo
tanto este elemento podríamos pasarlo
para acá y hacer la sumatoria de uno que
sería nuestro x sub y por lo tanto
pasando en limpio esto quedaría de la
siguiente manera vamos a usar otro color
vamos a decir que tenemos entonces la
sumatoria
tx subí al cuadrado menos dos veces la
media por la sumatoria ahora sí
de todos los x sub
más la media al cuadrado por la
sumatoria
de uno
la sumatoria de 1a n de un
y ahora si todo esto lo vamos a dividir
por n y en fin si realizamos un
denominador común
tranquilamente podríamos distribuir ese
denominador para cada uno de los
términos
de la siguiente manera
se comprende entonces pasando en limpio
todos estos signos vamos a colocarlos a
cabo
aunque tenemos un menos lo que tenemos
un más quiero quiero que se distingan
viendo la separación de los términos
tenemos acá los términos
con la n distribuida y fíjense lo
siguiente en el término segundo esta
cuestión
a que les hace acordar y si no les hace
acordar a nada les voy a recordar
recordemos que la media de la población
no era igual a la sumatoria
de todos los elementos de la población
/ el total de los elementos y es
exactamente igual a esto por lo tanto
nosotros podemos deshacernos de esta
parte
y deshacernos de esto y escribirlo
directamente
como tú
y nos deshacemos también de ese
denominador n
y también quiero prestar atención no
quiero llamarles la atención en esta
cuestión la sumatoria de todos los
elementos
de igual a uno hasta n de 1 esto va a
ser igual a todos esos elementos es
decir a n si sumamos tantas veces no1
sumamos o al número 1 lo sumamos n veces
es decir hacemos uno más uno más uno si
se ve
hacemos 111 así más 1 n veces
n veces vamos a obtener que esto es
igual a n
por lo tanto
también podemos
reescribir esto de la otra forma sobrar
acá
borramos esto y en vez de escribir toda
esa sumatoria escribimos directamente
por n
y ahora si podemos realizar otra
cuestión que es simplificar está n con
esta n por lo que en este tercer término
también se simplifica bastante y nos
queda solamente muy al cuadrado ahora
bien pasemos en limpio todo esto
sustrayendo de estos paréntesis y nos
queda que la sumatoria
como venimos haciendo todo este tiempo
de cada elemento al cuadrado o del
cuadrado de cada elemento s restado a 2
muy al cuadrado muy por mismo al
cuadrado más o al cuadrado va a ser
igual como venimos diciendo a nuestra
varianza que es igual a sigma al
cuadrado y fíjense cómo se simplificó la
cuestión
ahora bien si seguimos trabajando con
esto nosotros finalmente podemos decir
que menos dos mil cuadrados más es igual
a menos al cuadrado
por lo tanto podemos reescribir a la
varianza de una forma mucho más sencilla
que es la siguiente
esto va a ser igual entonces a la
sumatoria
igual a 1 n del cuadrado de todos los
elementos sobre n menos la media al
cuadrado o el cuadrado de la media
esto es igual entonces
a nuestra varianza y fíjense que es
realmente una fórmula mucho más sencilla
no tenemos que andar haciendo el
cuadrado de cada una de las diferencias
sino que hacemos el cuadrado de cada uno
de los elementos menos la media al
cuadrado y se acabó el problema ahora si
no conocemos la media tranquilamente
esto podríamos escribirlo de la
siguiente forma
nosotros sabemos que la media es la
sumatoria
de todos los elementos
sobre
el total de los elementos entonces esto
al cuadrado muy al cuadrado va a ser
todo esto
al cuadrado sobre el al cuadrado
por lo tanto que si escribimos esto así
de la siguiente manera
esto también va a ser otra alternativa
de la fórmula de la varianza cualquiera
de las dos o cualquiera de las tres si
tenemos en cuenta la primera son válidas
vamos a copiar nuevamente acá yo me
inclino siempre y casi sin pensarlo por
cualquiera de estas dos antes de que el
anterior porque se me hacen mucho más
sencillas pero siempre queda elección
del que trabaja o del que realiza los
experimentos son los problemas
simplemente yo les presento las
distintas alternativas